hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm checking in on ya I know
my voice is still [__] up I'll be back
or maybe I shredded it for life what am
i doing right now I'm sitting on a
pull-out couch than what is supposed to
be my office but no work gets done in
here
yeah I'm just [__] chilling out I got
a little half a grapefruit here that I'm
going to eat later
because old freckles is a fat [__] and
he turning it around that's what I'm
doing I'm turning it around I'm not
going to try to blame Hollywood for
[__] giving me an impossible body
image to live up to I'm going to I'm
going to use it as a goal all these
[__] [__] out there nowadays oh
that's too hard yeah it is hard eat an
apple get your fat ass to the gym that's
what America needs right there now for
this [__] I don't know what this
patty cake but [__] and playing with
everybody jesus [__] christ you live
in a great country
there's too many cookies all right know
that and leave the house it's all you
got to do [__] sitting here blaming
Arviso your fat ass huh hating on those
those [__] Victoria's Secret models
are whoever the new [__] Brad Pitt
guy is with his [__] 8 pack huh so
that's been airbrushed I'll [__] you
you're fat you ain't a big king every
[__] day for the last 20 days that's
your problem it's not society it's that
you have a car they have a drive-thru
and you have singles in your wallet
where you're going to spend it drive
your fat ass down to the supermarket
just like my doing midsection I'm
bringing it down there looking like the
[__] freckled imagine the Pilbara
Pillsbury Doughboy with like freckles
that's what I'm looking right now my
[__] shirt on put on a good 12 pounds
of writers room weight you know you know
what I like to go fry like the Hershey's
many inches right get that [__] sugar
rush and I'm like whoa whoa whoa then I
eat a handful of [__] pretzels bring
me back down with the salt
and then where am I Oh late night Oh
we're working late again tonight eyelets
get a [__] pizza I'm just going to
have one slice four slices on right down
the [__] pie hole and Who am I blame
it huh my blaming those [__] on
Instagram I'm not not me I'm taking
responsibility for my gluttonous acts I
am a [__] oh no I'm not a mess I'm
turning around little daddy white legs
hey get up to almost a buck eighty-six
you know now I'm back down to a buck 82
my goal is just to be in the 170s I'm in
the [__] one 70s by the time we're
done with the next two episodes right a
couple two three pounds over the next
two weeks right I can do that [__] even
though the fourth of July is coming up
right and that's the big day we
celebrate Independence Day you know
wasn't that today we had to fight with
the British and we said one if by land
two if by sea and I get those Native
Americans off my property
now isn't that what happened on that day
we declared independence from England on
July 4th 1776 we were like we're sick of
you oppressing us we would like to be
the oppressors and this took us almost
300 years to get there and goddamn it
with that we're doing it as good as
England ever did it take that [__]
anyways got a drink the throat cook -
you know why I never drank this before I
can't tell you know something that's
[__] delicious is a goddamn
grapefruit not a regular grapefruit a
goddamn grapefruit they're right next to
the Sunkist you go in there you hey you
got a goddamn grapefruit appetite we
only have Sunkist and then you say well
[__] you buddy
[__] you and your crate a celery that's
what I'm back to celery at night my
little scoop of [__] peanut right I'm
6 months into this year my drinking's
back under control
nothing will bring your drinking back
under control
like eight [__] Corona lights that
somebody left in my [__] fridge Jesus
Christ but slowly knocking those things
back one a day it's just
such a horrible experience by the end of
it was like I not only do I not want
another I don't think I want to drink
again
you know that's whatever so only had one
cigar this month so I've had nine for
the year so that's good right it's going
to go off the rails soon right we got
fourth of July and then I got [__]
the European blood coming up you know
and I was on a flight and I somehow
discovered this part of sag a sexy and
not oh it's places to smoke if you like
cigars people go on cigar aficionado
calm and you click on search cigar
aficionado 1/f who no I thought it was
spelt like after with two F's right
kidding I just love all the people when
I play A+ stupid I am they just love you
know you guys don't to make now get
right next to me at the Applebee's right
just order your fried [__] pickles
you [__] scarf sexy now no one F doesn't
[__] and Google Places to smoke I mean
it's just it's [__] it's incredible
so um I've done that all across Europe
but I just did it like every like fifth
city or something so I don't go off the
rails when I'm over there so I got a
couple of days in London I'm going to
smoke there and then I think I'm just
going to [__] haul ass for the rest
of the trip and maybe take a few days
off a little vacation little all a day
you know somewhere down the
Mediterranean right look at old fancy
freckles do you like this
what a [__] life slumped everything
in high school huh no you need two years
of a language now you know you just need
to be a silly [__] and have enough
people get into you and all of a sudden
you two you two cannot add up how much
your vacation costs and then get a
credit card bill would be like what the
[__] it's one of my favourite things I
might sound a little more jovial than
usual there's a reason for that there is
a fart as a [__] reason is the great
Sam Kinison which say aye
aye I finally bought a car daddy bought
it with
oh look who's here - love you Nia just
in time for me to talk about my new
[__] car let's turn up the mic Nene I
got to tell you I bought you know what I
bought yes I bought the BMW [__] magnet
that's what it's called no I didn't buy
a BMW
I bought a Jaguar and I ordered it I
bought a Jag and I ordered the color
because I didn't want to be another
douche driving a black white or [__]
red car they called me a douche driving
driving a what is it British racing
green yeah like every jag was supposed
to be oh you hate you hating on me right
now it's [__] beautiful guys it's
freezing in here you notice that I'm
wearing like oh yeah you're [__]
Apollo 13 jacket yeah go turn off the
a/c bombers because it was hot as hell
in here okay me I'm white the cold
doesn't affect me you know how I get on
the beach it look like I'm having a heat
stroke
you sitting there frolicking around we
isn't this great I'm under that giant
[__] umbrella looking like it was my
final wish to go to the beach for the
first time ever in my life
of my life remember that guy do you know
if somebody told me to buy on the on the
old interweb there it's Richard wrong
said on so yeah don't start saying
interwebs I love what he says that why I
love that guy did yourself some of that
cuz I look at him going he flunked
everything in high school - I need to
feel mated they put so much emphasis on
Vince's might in school you don't have
to cook everything in school what was it
when I say I flunked everything of the
ceiling the glass ceiling I couldn't
push through was seized and then there
was a bunch of DS and then just the UH
the math was just the old right there
Fred really Oh what about I've never
shown you my [__] I think I still I
I have his desk my parents don't throw
anything out it's still in there and
every once in a while there's this
little thing and I open it up - oh my
god really
Oh remember when I was showing you all
my
my achievement certificate yeah
opposites attract near but it's like a
bunch of DS C's and he it's just even
like English and stuff like that oh yeah
oh yeah I suck I stop getting A's and
B's right I did well until through
junior high and then when it counted
when the [__] colleges got to do more
than share the greatest thing the
greatest thing I ever did was completely
[__] up in high school because why
because if I did well if I did well and
I live the dream like and I was I got
accepted into a big-time college debt at
a great [__] football program and I
joined a frat and I had penny loafers
with no socks on and all that just
living the white guy dream we definitely
wouldn't be right if I did that like I I
just think I would have been doing so
well in life that getting into this
business never would have dawned on me I
would have been like well I can't leave
right I'm driving a convertible Audi I
got a I got the extra special cubicle
and I don't think I would have done it
but the fact that I [__] up so bad
that my options were only going
part-time to low level schools and
unloading trucks that then going and
doing an open mic it wasn't as scared
like what was I walking away from that's
true lower back pain I mean look at me
now sciatica
I think it's cured um penny loafers with
no socks I feel like that's a big red
flag to me like there's something about
it that I just yeah it's like when black
people in diapers with no socks that's
like when certain white people see black
guys and hoodies it's the same thing
yeah it is it well no it isn't because
of the power structure but it's the same
thing you're totally look at him you
look at those penny loafers with no
socks and you're like frat boy date
rapist I think they're a frat boy we
agreed to have aggressive sex and you
end up facedown dead in the park yeah
yeah actually exactly yes you're allowed
to say that right yeah
I'm not allowed to say that I'm not
allowed to see a black guy with a hoodie
at 12:00 midnight movie I always working
on an app they just came outside to
scratch his legs then I end up at a
trunk of a car ah but I just I do feel
that way and I know that that's a
stereotype and I know that that's wrong
why do you have density oh well you know
if I think about like why do you have
like Kennedy's and you have like you
have this Trump white eyeliner on here
oh no I do that's my eye cream that I
didn't fully blend in my skin oh god
you're spoiled I'm not spoiled I think
that's my eye cream it's down at night
if I have a samosa that's a bad
stereotype what is if not all preppy
guys preppy white guys or serial killers
or date rapist but I feel like if they
were to be they would get away with it
I just feel like it's a safe body of
money it's a safe thought to think as a
woman just go with the bad so you get
home in one piece
yeah if you think somebody's going to
eat you you got to go at that thought
yeah and just a point regardless of how
many people's feelings you hurt right
but like are you just people wearing
like so how do you think white people
should handle pants how do you think
white people should handle the other
situations and like both shoes and like
Blazers or like shorts with whales on
them man you got you got a you [__]
got this person down or like their hair
is is so perfect and they've got their
like collar pop just so on they're like
Ralph Lauren like yellow button down you
got issues with salmon shorts and like a
white belt with a blue stripe down the
middle of it so what if a guy like that
came walking up to you and started
talking you in the club I I was feeling
what is your name is it something ethnic
my name is Scott chose this whole
chancla scat
ah no I'm being very very Oh typical
right now there are plenty of those guys
that are part of the Yacht Club and the
Gulf and Glo and I'm are they're lovely
P where did you meet those people I've
never I'm really white I've never met
their season yeah I'm being I'm being
stereotypical and it's wrong
do you know one time I met he wasn't he
wasn't like a lost big I was a Jewish
guy right and I was at this wedding for
buddy mine was Jewish right so I was
like were the only Gentiles there and
eight I just moved to [__] Manhattan
and this guy [__] big lead to me
big-time right I was living on this out
walk through bedroom on 97 East 97th
Street right and you know crackhead
smokin I think the thing the total New
York experience like the first night I'm
laying in my single bed you know just
it's like a little kid bed and like a
roach walked across my chest a night and
I just thought that was part of I didn't
kill it I just thought it was part of
the New York experiences like I'm an I
need to get tough so I was like [__]
alright bugs are going to crawl on me I
can take this [__] right so I go to the
but I'm still excited german-irish Tuffy
[__] dope you guys will put up with
any DEP and that's why we die young it's
why we die young one day I'll let it all
out and I'll do that epic cry like that
black dude on the intervention cuz I
still do
watch that yesterday the cry of a man
who hasn't cried and like ever the baby
we watch that yesterday in the writers
room and then we watch one of the worst
ones ever because I love the guy Mike
Schmidt retiring from baseball we
watched that one and it's such a shame
you want to [__] that that guy gets
because he could literally at this still
at this age he could literally pick me
up and throw me out of the major league
in field I would land in shallow left
but he just goes like you know whatever
like I forget how it was like 20 years
ago a boy left blah blah blah Wisconsin
where the hell he was with the dream to
play major league baseball he went all
the way I was like oh no so somebody had
that video Major League Baseball and
then they immediately cut to the black I
got oh dude we [__] died we [__]
died and I was actually sitting there
when I was watching that how hard we
were all laughing I was wishing I could
reach out to the person that made that
because I would be psyched you know if I
wasn't in this business and a bunch of
people in a writers room writing on a
[__] show like we don't laugh at [__]
dude we will [__] dying so I mean I
wish my stand-up got that kind of
[__] lesson or writers omen Thor
what's the set of the tracking and all
of that [__] so um anyways alright so
where are we now we were talking about
your car
oh yeah Jaguar sorry about the Jaguar
Jaguar the XF I'm so [__] excited I'm
not excited that it doesn't come for its
100 days away that's what happens when
you order a custom color yes you don't
mind can I be excited about this I drove
a [__] Prius for nine years right
yeah I've been gay bashed for the better
part of a decade driving that Club yes I
can tell you that's a hot [__] car
though the Prius I've had two people
already offered to buy it good - can I
buy an auntie yes it has although it
smells you got it detailed at one time
and then we we came home and it was a
hot day and the windows were up
whatever that chemical was they put in
the seat it's [__] business bakes in
there and ya know how to get it out yeah
it's like somebody died in there that
cleans houses no wait it doesn't smell
like somebody died in there isn't just
got you know yeah yeah eat something and
you kind of think you like it and is
that weird aftertaste and you're like
well we can't sell it until we figure
out how to get rid of that you need to
learn to talk into the mic and there you
go
you know what they're not don't just
pick a height and hear me I'm attorney
up I'm all away sorry not because of you
hey I like that Remy Ma just because she
shot somebody that's [__] great so
many people in that genre act like they
would do [__] like that but the end of
the day like one of my [__] idiot
I got a Bentley I don't need to be
shooting people yeah she actually shot
somebody and she went to jail for it I
don't think she's like proud of it by
any means though well no you know what I
know I had to see her out and do I'm not
advocating shooting people what I'm
saying what's cool is is that if she
talks about [__] like that you know that
she's not pretending oh I certainly
wouldn't [__] with her yeah like I'm
still waiting for Robert Blake to put
out an album you know he [__] over
Blake yeah he plays guitar wait he's not
dead no he's out I went into a guitar
shop one time and he was in there no
yeah I'd I would run the other way he's
so scary yeah don't go to bed with a
price on your head no silly boy you
enjoyed watching the Beatty Awards with
me I did the whole prints tribute Nolan
[__] tremendous [__] tremendous I
don't know why you guys are upset about
the Oscars you guys have a better award
show just do one yourself and show us
how to do a good one I don't know why
the [__] you're trying to get there yeah
yeah generally seem to be more fun but
oh Jesus where the hell is on you no no
it's not more or less fun it's just
you're going to be able to be yourselves
I don't know who that is I don't know
what the [__] happened all of a sudden I
got on this list like congratulations
your business is one and just hang up
what chose me is they keep callin which
means somebody up it's enough people it
works on there's enough people that sit
there congratulations like holy [__]
Ellen get in here
is it an 8 for 4 member because I have
some weird 844 number that keeps calling
me and it's business but you know they
have those machines that like just try
every single combination of phone
numbers and whatever one hits and
someone picks up they're like hello I
have some exciting news for you yeah
it's not exciting it's [__] annoying
you know what the worst is when I'm out
walking Cleo and I'm listening to some
song right I'm listening to some song so
of course any song that I listen to I am
on stage with the band playing drums and
I'm killing it and they're all turning
around looking at me like wow this guy
has more Skills than we thought that's
what I do the entire time I'm out there
yeah fantasize and all of a sudden the
phone comes on and I'm a whenever it's a
random number I just think it's some
radio station that I used to do and
that's always good for business I pick
up the phone I make people laugh
Drivetime you know whatever I'm not even
in the city and they're hearing me make
them laugh maybe it'll come up to a show
so I always pick up and I'll be like in
the middle of was Allison Queens of the
Stone Age today I listen to them and
others own gain in a decade a day they
did nicotine value Beca - I wanna
alcohol the cocaine but it is
yeah I'm just [__] listen - of course
I'm on the drugs weren't gay gay gay gay
gay gay kick it like [__] kill with
it Josh's Teran drunk oh wow
right totally impressed which will not
happen right so I can dream and then the
[__] photo ring he's impressed with
you but not for your musical skills I
know he's not impressed me why would you
say that and ruin this great story sorry
he [__] so I'm walking I was treating
the [__] phone rings and then I
stopped listened to that and I [__] a
pickup is like a graduation your fantasy
is over a year your business
I want a free trip to a robot so even if
you know you don't have a radio station
so you'll just still pick up random
numbers yeah you have also why would you
know hey Jeff I think you you ever think
you ever like dialed somebody you don't
you dial the number incorrectly so I
guess you don't do it that much anymore
but every once in a while you just
[__] dial a number you dial it wrong
you ever think you actually called
somebody famous like they have phones
they got to get wrong numbers they don't
pick up numbers that they don't
recognize yeah oh you don't think JLo
picks up like huh whatever she sounds
like what as ago she goes I'm just I'm
just like this why you wouldn't pick up
like yo Clinton said yo Clinton picks up
random numbers oh of course he does yeah
you know he does he's was hmm oh good I
don't know what now he's looking like
very frail ah yeah he's old he vegan now
so I feel like that way he looks like a
scarecrow that came to life if a
scarecrow [__] a snowman the Scarecrow
[__] a snowman that's what he looks
like
because he sees his pasty as a snowman
and it's skinny I've never felt more
alive it comes at us it's [__]
chicken neck um can we talk about how
you kind of like to like in the same
vein as you picking up numbers and being
like yeah sure or how you just don't pay
attention what stuff like what happened
when I asked you to get Minute Rice and
grapefruit what did you bring home
cantaloupe and a regular rice that took
20 minutes I thought Uncle Ben's was
always minute right I thought he had
shipped the dope
I haven't dentally I see I was wrong Ben
can hang around okay one we cantaloupe
what you want for me was delicious
though wasn't it was I just feel like
you just get a vague idea of like what's
supposed to happen just kind of run with
it like you're like oh it's around
melon fruit or something not even a
melon you weren't even was good at melon
just you just knew it was round and it
was probably next to the grapefruit if
you just grabbed it not thinking yeah
you want to do you know it sure all
right so I bought you a nice [__] car
right and you park it under a tree so I
got this [__] B top B tarp that fits
your car like a [__] glove and you're
not putting it on and the [__] saps
coming down on your car so I sit there I
go near why don't you put the top on the
car like is there any way somebody can
trim back the tree it's like or you
could just put the [__] tarp on the
car I know but I also feel like that
tree needs to be cut back in general why
that tree is right outside can hear you
right now
don't worry buddy you're not going
anywhere just dropping those weird
things all over the place that's called
nature that's called nature Nia we live
we shouldn't even be out there that tree
should be out okay I'm not saying that
you should cut it down and I guess you
could just cut it back that's all inside
it cut it back or maybe like cut it so
that it grows why don't you just put the
[__] tarp on the car well then there
you go it's salt yeah you do have a
problem cuz I went down and there was
[__] all over your car and I playing
[__] last night and what happens is a
lot of people don't know this I learned
this the hard way what happens is I'm
explaining this and I know you don't
like this but I'm explaining when the
[__] SAP gets on your [__] car you
got it not talked to you you got to get
it off because what happens is when your
car heats up the paint expands and then
at night when it cools off it contracts
again and it's like a motion night the
SAP in the paint become one it's like a
tattoo and then it's underneath you
[__] paint and you can't get it out
at least that's what the guy at the
carwash told me because it was like hey
what about these spot series like my
friend my friend
why not Fred tell me what happened so I
like your blue dress thank you I got
yesterday where'd you get it
Topshop Topshop yeah is that expensive
now I'll actually good good job Nene get
a red one - I like Topshop
the Monday morning podcast sponsored by
Tasha Topshop that would be great well
you too why because it send me some
dresses yeah that fit me ideally I'm the
host
I get the dresses so you excited about
the Austrian Grand Prix on Sunday sure
yeah you know what all you need to go is
to one of those races once you see the
[__] who has at that [__] thing
the money I should say we're gonna go to
the Grand Prix and Markel at some point
I'd love to yeah I'd love to and just go
there like a people know is a dumb
American just annoy all those rich
people all right I got a read here are
like a USA's a little bit of uh oh yeah
that one somebody had on yesterday had
the American flag back-to-back World War
champs you gotta weigh that over in
Europe oh my god they would just cringe
if there's nothing better than just
playing into who they think you are
anyways here we go loot crate everybody
give me the loot with loot crate you get
collectibles apparel and more from your
favorite pop culture franchise delivered
right to your door every single month
we're talking a new t-shirt and every
crate figures comics and stuff for your
kitchen oh this is this comic-con [__]
nia a wide range of it you can have like
an Aquaman spatula you know a spider-man
jug of milk you know Robin pajama
bottoms okay you know and then Batman on
top because he's definitely a Zeidan
that day sorry oh sorry we're talking a
new t-shirt Nona a wide range of
exclusive items you can't get anywhere
else from a fan favorite franchise like
Harry Potter
Marvel Comics fallout 4 [__] was I when
the first three came up Star Wars and so
much more what is fallout 4 is that a
band you're thinking Fall Out Boy or
some forty one and you can get all of
this for less than $20 a month matchbox
20 remember everything at a number look
loot crate come geek out with us loot
crate is a monthly subscription box
service for epic geek and gamer items
and pop-culture gear for less
twenty dollars a month you get 68 items
that include licensed gear parable
collectibles unique one-of-a-kind items
and more this is going to be [__]
huge people love this [__] you have
until the 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific time to
subscribe and receive this month's crate
and when the cutoff happens that's it
it's over make sure to head to WWII comm
/ / and enter code ber to save three
dollars on any subscription there you go
oh my god Nia we got to talk sports here
should I leave no you know what yes just
the way you just said that
yeah hi there and you're looking at your
phone yep Kardashian tone right now it's
really I'm not I just how about I just
you know I don't know anything about
sports so call me when we know a little
bit can you believe PK subhan got traded
for Shay Webber I know that you were
just couldn't stop talking about it this
morning while we're still I couldn't
believe I thought he was a handful life
I [__] hate when that happens
you know Joe bartnick talked me off the
ledge he said [__] Nashville needed a
staff and something about the haves
needed to be a little more solid and
tougher on defensive some [__] like that
so I guess it's a good trade who the
[__] knows but I hate when big stars
like that that's why I was psyched
Steven Stamkos we signed with Tampa like
you know he he's like me I can't say el
lightning it's such a stupid [__] I
hate when they main teams after weather
whatever PK's I had man that's [__] up
even as a Bruins fan I'm gonna miss like
you know I never really hated the guy
he's one of those guys he was so [__]
good you couldn't hate him you know I
mean the Montreal Canadiens fans however
you know this silly sucks and little
pockets squeezed in yeah all right I got
to wrap this thing up because I have to
go we're doing the record for actually
still number eight we're writing number
nine everybody I'm coming out the
[__] what's that thing that comes out
to the Gopher right ground lock
groundhog pokes its [__] head on you
might if my head came up honey
how many more [__] weeks of winter
would that be alright that's 30 minutes
go to be alone winter it's going to be a
long winter I never forget 2016
the roundest wedges head Emma came out
of that hole got an email about a
seven-night Mediterranean cruise Harding
from Greenwich starting at 899 but I
don't think that's what kind of thing
are we underneath the boat we like I
think that's that the refugee special I
think that's what kind of thing where
it's like we have to work on the boat
which other and like 4,000 other people
at the at the buffet line yeah you can't
even get a cruise for that there's no
[__] way you're getting on that what
does the boat look like I don't know
yeah well I don't know I'll have to I'll
have to do something evil to ever be
able to afford that but it's nice to
notice alright that's it that's the
Thursday afternoon podcast for um wait a
minute
what night yeah it's go work I couldn't
work the pyramid game that's the only
reason why me oh [__] all right let's do
the pyramid game alright where are we I
don't want to make you late should we
save it for you no no let's do it I said
we want to do when I come on is a
holiday are you gonna do watch Steve are
you gonna do a podcast on the 4th of
July
yeah go sir no days off yeah this see
how much fun this [__] is ok so I
[__] around the advertising I don't give
a [__] if they hear or not I'm still
going to do it alright so those of you
weren't listening the past week got
[__] what do you say there what do we
do the $10,000 pyramid yes because it
all came about because we were talking
about how you just notoriously sort of
just guessed things wrong or it was
really more about how your your movie
titles that's how it started yeah you
know well I just I don't know the length
of Dracula bed of saying Pearl Jam I'd
be like a flannel shirt oh I'm in a
trance this musics making me go crazy I
don't like George Bush right exactly but
I knew that one that's Eddie better yeah
so that is playing playing the pyramid
game alright
so evidently I sucked at giving clues
let's see if you're better alright you
ready
oh wait so I'm going first no it's your
turn I gave last time you received like
I thought I also gave I thought we both
know no we did we both did
it doesn't matter but now you do do you
have them in your head oh you stink you
were supposed to make a list I know
what's there for next time then no you
can't do that to people
I'm sorry people well I'm gonna hit
pause you're going to do it right now
all right they're gonna be easy all
right we're bad she said they're going
to be don't make them easy it's just
three okay here we go let's get the
clock going here
all right and go so Michael Jordan has
won a ring that's quarry a mistress a
mystery think that Seth quarry has one
of the people think they're ugly
I'm sure the Brawn has a haircut makers
yeah thank you okay um they're not
native to California but they're
everywhere the avocados they provide
shade people uh Real Housewives them
Real Housewife all fixes a me
victus they're natural palm trees yeah
Graham um fourth of July celebration
back pops heart attacks they're in this
America fireworks yeah oh come on that
was a joke yeah I was too easy then you
know what you just made me feel like I
was special come up think of a difficult
one right now some obscure so I can
guess okay you got it all right 3 a 2 a
1 there a big huge animal that smells
good you think cheetah they're in the
water cats they're vicious skirt sharks
barracudas whales but they're they can
run fat during the water they run fast
frogs they're very platypus services and
they attack you barracuda they're in an
iPhone commercial and it says at the end
I thought I'm in - guys could you hear
me now there were a game a game from the
Monopoly 70s and 80 why any more 80s
there was a bunch of them in a ring jaws
and they had to eat and let you and your
song animal in the water
a big fat animal whale just a wall runs
in the field and in the game goes four
of them in each corner and you and your
friends like hit it and they
and for like Oh a hippo yes I thought
you meant the ocean ah [__] that
something like three minutes to get you
should have said that hungry hungry good
my bill wanted to be so easy oh there
you go
I could have done better no that was
good see you make them hard they make
them hard then it's a bit less longer
okay make it easy
maybe shutting you open with it rain
umbrella okay
alright I have to go alright on hundred
more days counting down that's right
can't wait alright that's the Thursday
afternoon podcast enjoy the music that's
coming up have a great July 4th weekend
thank you to everybody in this country
that's come out to my shows and thank
you to England for losing that great
battle today on July 4th right then they
lose a battle then we signed a paper
like ah you [__] we got you now
I know I know what it is we declared I
remember that I just like doing it
because it makes them feel superior
that's right where you want to just
coming in what do they call themselves
cozy smug [__] and then um the old
right there Fred alright that's it go
[__] yourselves have a wonderful weekend
I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
you
come on
me
Oh
[Music]
Hey
ah
Oh
Hey
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Dilbert's the
Monday morning podcast for what the hell
today June 29th June 30th the [__] is
the date I don't know how it is it's the
last Monday in June and I can't believe
how much the summer is just flying by J
when somebody say say that every [__]
summer you know you know it's going to
fly by because the weather's awesome
because it's fun it's like eating
cookies you know you open a bag you
think you're just going to have one next
thing you know the whole bags gone you
know why because they taste delicious do
you really need some douche bag to stand
there next to you going like can you
believe how good those cookies were I
can't believe they're already gone I
wish someone would say that in the
winter can you believe how fast the
winners going by what kind of person
would say that huh some sort of mountain
man who's into snowboarding
alright that was awesome I don't [__]
alright it's the money more for Monday
June 30th sorry okay I was riffing and I
was looking up what the date was all
right as I've told you guys in past
podcast I have one of the oldest still
functioning laptops out there I told you
mine is it's actually made out of birch
I got it down at the pottery barn back
when they used to sell laptops a lot of
people don't know that they think that
they were just into furniture but there
was a moment there where they tried to
branch out into computers and
electronics and needless to say it
failed and actually you know what I was
thinking about getting a new laptop but
uhm good friend of mine told me how to
add more memory to this one so I'm
thinking why the [__] why would I go out
and get a new one I don't understand why
people keep going out and buying new
laptops like they're [__] Steven
Spielberg in the dumping like hours of
film footage you're not doing it okay
they cost like two three [__] grand
what are you doing you don't I mean you
ever just stop and think what the [__]
doing just get off the goddamn [__]
hamster wheel for a second and just
realize how ridiculous it is that you
spend twenty five hundred dollars on
something and it's acceptable that the
thing is going to [__] the bed within
[__] two years then two years
something's going to happen you know the
battery is going to mess up and then
you're going to go down to the MAC store
or the [__] Bill Gates store or
whatever the hell they got out there and
they're gonna be like yeah it's not
under warranty can we fix a year we can
fix it but or to fix it for some stupid
[__] reason is going to cost twenty
one hundred and a new laptop is twenty
five so you know I mean we'll fix it but
you know the whole thing is [__]
[__] there's no reason they should
cost that much you know what you know
something if nerds had any [__]
brains the amount of [__] they would be
getting right now just by fixing their
friend's laptops and saving everybody
twenty five hundred bucks instead of
charging people eighteen hundred why
don't you judge charged like five
hundred bucks you [__] nerds go out
you know buy something flashy that
always attracts the [__] they like
that you know now just give yourself a
little makeover with with you with your
laptop fixing abilities money you know
like one of those bad 80s movies you can
turn your life into like a montage you
know play some song like the Fine Young
Cannibals and some chick takes you to
the mall you know takes off your glasses
I always hated that in those [__]
movies like we'll never like somebody
you know whenever they were going to
have like like the nerdy chick all all
of a sudden become gorgeous right like
the way they made her ugly was they put
her hair up and they made her wear black
frame glasses you know what I mean like
you still couldn't see that she was
gorgeous you know and then they just
take her hair down and then she take off
her glasses and it was like oh my god
who is that you know and then the date
rape is football player comes up to her
and then she always like like no I don't
think so you know you didn't like me
when I
when I had my hair up and I was wearing
these glasses okay but there's nerd over
here he always liked me so now we're
going to go to the prom and we're going
to dance and that's going to be the end
of the [__] movie okay and I always
hated that moment in the movie because
it always reminded me that I was
watching a movie because in real life
okay that girl as much as she liked the
nerd she wouldn't like him in that way
okay they can't help but send their
[__] DNA they want to breed with the
strongest [__] in the room and I don't
care how much of a dick that guy that
quarterback was being toward the second
she got the attention that that was
filler up because all those years they
having her hair up wearing those [__]
Malcolm X glasses gave her low
self-esteem and she she would at least
for a four to six year period would have
to go out and fill herself up with
please accept me [__] you know before
she kind of was able to regroup and be
like you know what these guys are
[__] I wonder what that nerds up to
and by then it'll be too late
because nerds generally you know they
marry the first thing that a lot of let
him [__] him you know so by the time she
you know she runs through you know
sometime she found a [__] the
placekicker that nerd is already married
with three kids and he invented he
invented the ice wait a minute no he's
he's [__] and then these damn laptops
that got a depth I got to get repaired
every couple of years that's their
[__] payback Wow
I just figured that out that's why
there's no goddamn nerds out there being
able to fix these [__] laptops for
500 bucks it's all 1,800 bucks is in
that that when they gave the [__]
nerdy chick the makeover she still blew
the quarterback so now we got to pay for
it
spots ridiculous man all right this is
the Monday morning podcast and my name
is Bill burr I do one of these every
[__] Monday and you know give you
some laughs about and you know keep you
in my thoughts actually keep me in your
thoughts that's why I'm doing this I'm
not doing it because I give a [__] about
you people I'm trying to give you guys a
reason to keep coming back to my site
and maybe I'll tell other people to come
too
my site so the next time I go to Raleigh
North Carolina I'm not standing in front
of 25 people you know so then I can make
some more money and then I can buy some
shiny [__] and then I can make up for
the fall all the [__] posting I never
got in high school see how that works so
anyways I do one of these every week I
talk about stuff that I have coming up
in my career I talk about comedy dates
and you know whatever like like it is a
great example for you I have a upcoming
CD DVD release I just like saying that
CD DVD released and a one-hour comedy
central's special and that will be shown
I believe it's August 23rd will be shown
the first time CDs coming out in August
CD I don't have an exact date yet and
the DVD is coming out in September I
don't have an exact date for that I just
have a month at this point
okay so cool you [__] Jets all right
we got July 4th coming up just relax
there's plenty of holidays between now
and the goddamn release and when I get
the information I'm going to let you
know what's up so that's what I have
coming up ok it's got to be in a [__]
during that so let me try to let me try
to say it a little more clear in August
I have a CD coming out and a one-hour
Comedy Central special and in September
the DVDs coming out so by October you
guys should all be sick of me but by
then hopefully I'll be filthy stinking
rich I'll have a brand new Ludwig drum
kit and a big house and I'll stand up
there you know naked with the bathrobe
that's partially open looking down on
the city realizing that I'm still empty
inside ok but we're going to cross that
bridge when we get to it man all right
people ask me questions every week on my
podcast and I like to try to answer them
people also send me in stories they give
me information what do you want to start
with first you want to start with the
questions you want to go with the
stories how about a story let me scroll
down here okay last week you know people
were talking about their cars getting
[__] up and everything like that
god dammit somebody sent me a funny one
and I forgot the copy and paste but I
got to read that one next week
I told you last week I was going to tell
you the second half basically everyone
was telling me these stories about how
their car got [__] up and then
everybody's story they were the victim
except for this one dude who talks about
how he was hitting on some [__] chick
and she doesn't want to hook up with
them so he goes out in the parking lot
hammered and backs his car into another
truck and I was trying to tell him you
know you're not really the victim there
so it's kind of hard to feel bad for you
so what the [__] did the girl do that
made you do something like that that we
should all feel bad for you me and my 14
podcast listeners should feel bad for
you so here goes this this is the other
half this is his reason for doing that
[__] okay hey Bill thanks for reading my
story sharing my gloom with everyone
haha let me tell you what happened with
girl number one
all right this is why he got he got
pissed in the club was a little tipsy
drunk gun in his car evidently did not
look stomped on the gas and back into a
truck [__] his car up and didn't do
[__] to the truck all right he said all
right being the girl we've been working
together for about a year now and
everyone in this building would like to
get with her we've been on and off
talking a lot or not at all it's a big
company
she's kind of a teeth she's kind of a
tease okay well you know I'm gonna take
your word for it but I mean kind of
she's a good-looking woman you know
she's got a lot of [__] coming at her
and you know maybe she's a little
defensive anyways she's kind of a tease
but he'll I don't care she say I'm hot
and I haven't sealed the deal yet all
right now I'm rooting for you that's
right go in there and [__] hit it all
right I was damn sure that this was the
night I was going to hook up with her
because we were hanging out and talking
a lot for the few weeks leading up to
this particular night out since it was
her birthday okay so here he is
you know chat her up for two weeks he's
go in the patient room as opposed to
those other guys who are walking into
the cubicle with their pants already
half unzipped you know I respected
everybody likes the full-court press but
that usually doesn't work especially if
you weren't Dockers it's just creepy so
anyway so this guy you know works it's a
two weeks now it's a birthday okay
and let's see and apparently most girls
like to get down on the day when the
clock rolls over okay I'm with you
anyway I completely fumbled the ball by
not paying enough attention or not
flirting enough that night assumption
and I got pissed when I knew that this
was probably the last chance I had which
then led to the aforementioned story so
basically you did two weeks of
reconnaissance he went out there it was
a birthday and you're trying to hit on
her
to close the deal and basically every
other hot chick that walks by you're
looking at him you know what there's not
one person in their early 20s that does
not have that [__] story that it's
just what it is it's just [__] is too
it's still too amazing for you with
you're in your thirties you'll be able
to block out the other [__] and you'll
be able to focus on your target and of
course by then you'll be in your 30s so
you'll be hitting on some cougar as they
say I hate that [__] word and I hate
those broads who think they're still
[__] hot like they're 22 okay I'm not
saying that hot for a 43 year old but we
stopped wearing [__] that 22 year old
chicks wear you know and me I just
turned 40 okay my days of wearing a half
shirt and [__] the socks up to my
knees like I'm in that movie dazed and
confused you know to me you look at me
like I was a [__] all right stop it
you're hot for your age you look good
for your age okay
so let's leave it at that okay let's uh
you're in your dressing elegant years
you're in your dress classy okay you
know once you're past [__] you know I
don't know someone you mid 30s if you're
still dressing like a jello shot girl I
don't know what to tell you know what
that's like that's like the [__] the
formal muscle head who stopped working
out but he still has the Hulk Hogan
wardrobe you know so he still got on the
tank tops but now he's got those flabby
grandmother arms and it's just like dude
you need to get a full shirt or start
doing some curls because yeah it's
working it look like Billy Crystal's
grandmother and mr. Saturday night
number down and they can sandwiches out
of her arm the fat on the back of her
arm all right so anyway let's I want it
so you got this cuz you you weren't able
to close the deal when you backed up and
smashed your car that's actually [__]
hilarious
that's a whole different segment the car
stories I was trying to get people to
tell is you know you went in to go buy
some face moisturizer and you came out
and your bumper was gone
you know the whole I didn't do [__] and
somebody raped me stories
I guess you created a new one people who
[__] up their car cuz they were trying
to [__] the hot chick at work on her
birthday and uh I don't know they looked
at some other chick I don't know what
happened anyways whatever man Domanick
feel bad here okay is a last story I'm
going to read here alright bill your
rants on American Airlines ring true as
they screwed a marine I met while on
vacation I don't know if you guys listen
to this [__] every week but American
Airlines [__] me over a while back to
the point I did a Puff Daddy remix of
their song when little snot like this
we're American and like [__] you in
Liege assh so you can still get it on
the air
alright so this is this is this guy's
story alright while returning from
Mexico I was in DFW Airport I love our
people right there DFW like I know what
the [__] that means is that Detroit
[__] where port Oh Dallas Dallas
Dallas Fort Worth there we go
the Delaware all right I don't know
Detroit's [__] I don't know I
whatever the [__] guy is he's a DFW
Airport okay and I in for all you pilots
out there eight people to overflowing
into LAX Cali X is actually great JFK
LAX people know that but stop saying DFW
like I know where the [__] that is
alright I was in DFW Airport and that's
it novio see I'm in the OC really I
don't know what the [__] that is Orange
County I still don't know what that is
it's south of Los Angeles thank you
thank you you mean that place that
nobody [__] goes to in between Los
Angeles and San Diego all right I was in
DFW Airport and met this guy at the tram
oh just [__] it's that word just makes
my skin crawl call the airport seven
minutes I was at the tram I met this guy
at the tram was fuming mad he told me he
was headed to to Gulfport Mississippi
from California and the plane had engine
trouble and had to return he then caught
the next flight and then had to land in
Dallas due to bad weather
he was then told that also all flights
out were on standby and while talking to
the gate agent the employee got pissy
with them what a [__] surprise he
mentioned that he had orders and needed
help getting any flight out and the
clerk said sir I can't help you please
enjoy your night in the airport after
the marine calmed down I asked him what
airline he was on he replied
[__] American Airlines they
suck I hope they go under Jesus Christ
they even [__] over a guy with me in
uniform Siri can help you please enjoy
your night in the airport really please
enjoy this [__] Ken Valenti I already
said the c-word enough of mr. goddamn
thing it's ridiculous you know something
in you know just go on their website
just start complaining I'm really trying
to do that [__] you know what I mean
somebody's got to do something you know
what I mean somebody [__] do
something do they respond when you
complain somebody sent me a [__]
email about they return something at
Best Buy and they charge them a 15%
restock fee which basically they bought
something it sucked they brought it back
okay if it cost a grand they charge them
150 bucks just to put it back on the
shelf so they still make money so
personally I never shop in the Best Buy
again that's it I'm done that's what I'm
saying that's just like you know what
I'm not eating fast food ever again man
so it basically means I'm not [__]
with Best Buy for three months I don't
know I'm sorry so let's get let's get on
with the questions okay
it's [__] this podcast started off
really good and now it's just it's
grinding to a [__] halt
see if I can up the comedy here take it
up a notch okay this podcast is like
it's like the Lakers in Game six you
know what I mean I never seen a team
with less heart Jesus Christ or Celtics
are up by 40 points they're still
shooting three-pointers you think war
they would have put up with that Kareem
those guys would have been throwing
elbows Larry Bird and all them would
have been holding up the trophy looking
like Bobby Clarke and the Lakers just
stood there and watched it all right
questions a number one by the way I'm a
Celtics fan and yes I am totally psyched
I'm sick all you Laker fans talking like
me up up is this Bynum guy like he's the
second coming of [__] Bill Russell
and Michael Jordan okay you guys need to
work on your heart first why don't you
draft a [__] heart first and then
talk to me about you know [__] kid a
coming off the goddamn bench because I
don't give a [__] Oh got a little
hostile there alright question number
one though when a comedian says the
Comedy Central Presents is there an
applause-o-meter because sometimes it
seems like an odd place for an applause
break also is there an opening act to
warm up the crowd let's see if there are
applause-o-meter
no they just actually I think they just
edit it in they'll take applause from a
different joke that really killed and I
don't know maybe because there's a lull
and for some reason they think the
viewer at home isn't going to notice or
like when they cut to somebody who's
laughing hysterically at another joke
that was hysterical that maybe even that
comedian didn't even tell they'll
actually if they get a good laugh erm in
the crowd they use that as stock footage
you know kind of like you know battle
footage you know like they're you know
when they show the atom bomb it didn't
have like two or three views of that
stock footage of the [__] atom bomb
that's the same it's the same thing it's
in stand-up comedy okay some lady lost
his [__] laughing in 1983 you haven't
ever noticed that sometimes like they'll
cut to somebody really bad like on det
they'll cut to somebody with a hairstyle
that is just like from [__] 20 years
ago you know what I mean like remember
black people used to have the three
level like high-top fade like three
different levels there was like a
parking garage or like some sort of
fancy stairs that would lead into like a
serving room or some [__]
remember that you know during the Bobby
Brown my prerogative that's what they'll
do they'll show a guy black dude or a
white dude whatever on comic view and
I'll tell a [__] joke you know they
dress you know they got an Obama know a
t-shirt right the comedian and then
they'll cut to somebody who looks like
one of the guys and [__] boys to men
it's worn like one of those lime green
[__] 7up sport coats okay yeah I
think I think I overly explain that all
right also is there an opening act to
warm up the crowd if you're lucky yes
there is if there isn't it sucks because
it's like nobody's laughing they're just
sitting there and all of a sudden you
come out and you just like what's up
with lamps these things crazy it's
really shocking so hopefully there there
is a warm-up act all my experiences that
happen okay question up to the question
is why does asparagus make your pitch
think just like that you said piss you
know like they should have been the
f-word in that sense it's just just to
prepare me for piss
I should have been why did your lightest
asparagus make your urine smell or what
is [__] asparagus make acoustic you
know I mean you got to be consistent
here the first half you're like dan
Rather
reading off a teleprompter and then you
know the second half you go and dice
clay on me all right asparagus contains
others this is the answer I actually
looked it up this is the first thing I
saw so I'm going with this like it's the
truth asparagus contains a sulfur
compound called mercaptan it's also
found in rotten eggs onions garlic and
in assistance in the secretion of skunks
when your digestive tract breaks down
this substance byproducts are released
they cause the funny sense the funny
scent I don't think it's funny you guys
think it's funny it's actually kind of
disgusting the process is so quick that
your urine can develop the distinctive
smell within 15 to 30 minutes of eating
asparagus see sources for more info
I left that last part in that
in case I actually tried to play that
off like I wasn't reading it so that's
why it does it you know because there's
some sort of sulfur compound called
mercaptan that's also fun and rotten
eggs onions garlic and in the secretion
of skunks you know I mean that's just
one of those [__] things at the
second you hear just forget it
okay because there's no way to say that
at a party and it's going to get you any
further with the person you're talking
to you know either talking them into bed
or trying to get a promotion that's just
like it just makes you weird and people
just sort of rate raised their eyebrows
and nod and [__] walk away and you're
left with awkward silence and that's
when you take out your cell phone you
pretend you got a call you don't have a
call all right question number three now
this is a great question so who is more
badass Tie Domi above Probert for those
of you who don't watch hockey these are
two of the all-time great enforcers in
NHL history who's more badass this is
tied o me or Bob Probert it's not even a
question it's [__] Bob Probert
not in not even I'm not even talking
about at the height of his career where
he beat the [__] out of every tough guy
and let me beat the [__] out of every
tough guy in the league he didn't start
losing fights towards the end okay so
everybody knows what he did on the ice
this is what he did off the ice he's a
little blur by finding him on the
Internet
former NHL enforcer Bob Probert Bob
Probert so I don't do the news I can't
even read his back in jail he was
arrested Friday night in Delray Beach
after a scuffle with Florida police that
led to Probert being shocked with the
taser gun this is this what he's doing
after his career when he's supposed to
be out on the golf course
hanging out with Charles Barkley doing
cell phone commercial charged with
battery on a law enforcement officer
resisting arrest with violence and
disorderly conduct
Probert was held without bail at the
Palm Beach County Jail while playing for
Detroit Red Wings in the 80s and 90s
Probert served a prison term when he was
caught trying to carry cocaine into the
United States from Canada he also had
alcohol problems it was charged with
numerous driving offences for over
Probert was placed on inactive status
for the 80s 94 to 95 season after he was
involved in a motorcycle accident
showed alcohol and cocaine in his system
this is what he does off the ice is what
he was doing off ice during his career
he probably had three fights that night
beat the [__] out of a whole nother team
that still wasn't enough
he's like a tinkled you know drink a 12
pack of [__] Schaeffer
you know get an eight ball and jump on a
[__] ninja delray police officers
first spotted Probert this is a this is
for my July June 4th 2014 to his 40s at
this point all right they spotted him on
Friday as he was parked in his white BMW
sport utility vehicle the wrong way on a
side street and began hanging out his
window to yell at several men before
1:00 a.m. and he was out of his mind
your [__] [__] you know who I am
that last [__] broker he probably
still wearing the hockey gloves I bet
like he has to do that he has he has to
drop gloves before he could fight or
it's just like it's like Nomar Nomar
Garciaparra before he hits he's got to
[__] you know click his feet in his
shoes and just his gloves
you know his batting gloves if any he
literally has to walk around in hockey
gloves or he won't he won't get the
first couple of shots off so anyways for
officers intervened when Probert a
native of Windsor Ontario got out of the
car and tried to start a fight with one
of the men going to the report he then
fought with the officers and refused
their orders to drop to the ground as
two of the officers struggled a
handcuffed Faubourg officer Thomas
Tolbert shot him with a taser gun and he
fell backward but Probert continued to
resist their efforts when they tried to
handcuff him this after getting tasered
so Tolbert used the Taser gun to stun
Probert several more times
and it's just [__] unreal the gun
shoots Bob probes yeah that's that
barbed wire [__] I hope you guys know
like it's not like science fiction where
they just shoot electricity at you it
shoots out these two medieval [__]
Inquisition hooks in a hook under your
skin into your chest like [__] Eagle
talons like that's not enough to make
you just scream like a [__] and drop to
the ground
they then shoot electricity into that
okay it's bad enough the guys already
fighting to cop see no cops okay that
little cops are like they have like mini
UFC skills they all know arm bars and
choke holds and they have guns and clubs
and [__] and he's fighting two of them
they still have to taser two or three
more times so I would don't Bob Probert
I would say Bob Probert it's a little
tough in the tide oh me okay until Kaido
me fights for [__] cops in his
mid-40s and has to get Taber's tasered
numerous [__] times I'm going to go
with Bob Probert and I don't have sent
any sort of [__] hockey geek come on
here and talk to me about [__] career
stats bring out type dummies arrest
record all right has he been arrested I
don't even look it up that's how [__]
up Roberts arrest record was I don't
even have I didn't have the decency to
look up Tie Domi so there you go all
right I got to wrap this thing up here
this is getting too long there's a
couple more questions I'll ask interim
real quick have you ever done any work
on a cruise ship yes I did and they
won't be asking me back the captain
wrote a letter said I was offensive to
all races said I made fun of handicapped
people because I did a joke about
midgets you know I don't I don't know
what to tell you you know I was told
didn't I already answer this question
did I answer this question they told me
is going to be young people and then I
got on the cruise ship and the first
person I saw was that old Vietnamese
lady lady with no teeth asleep with
their mouths open wearing that I'm
picking rice hat then I tell you I told
you that right
I don't [__] remember all right let's
get on with okay that that's the podcast
a week I'm going to tell you some of my
my [__] my dates I have coming up
here my slow computer June 2008
all right Oh big day here I got the
improv in Pittsburgh coming up July 10th
through the 13th I'm actually coming in
town now the day before because I'm
going to be going to that Pirates game
so if you go to the Pirates game I'm
sure you can be able to see me because
it's going to be me and 18 other [__]
people just sitting up there at the
goddamn game but that's uh
July 10th through the 13th and then July
31st through August 3rd I'm going to be
at the comedy I'm sorry August 2nd I'll
be at the Comedy Works in Denver
Colorado and August 14th through the
17th I'll be at the improv in Miami then
I got a bunch of other dates coming up
because right on the 23rd of August my
my specials coming out and then I'm
going to be doing a tour and information
will be coming out soon all right so
keep the questions coming let me know
how you guys think a story sometimes I
think the stories are good sometimes I
think kind of slows me down from joking
around I don't know if they're boring or
if they're interesting please let me
know please give me a feedback I'll
probably regret saying that because now
I'm going to get a bunch of yeah and you
stutter too much during them and blah
blah blah so why would I open myself up
to more criticisms in life anyways
thanks to everybody I really appreciate
all you guys listening I know I say only
have 14 listeners I know it's a lot more
than that it's got to be at least 32 at
this point and I really appreciate you
guys keep telling me that you like them
as long as you tell me to keep liking
them I'm gonna keep doing them and if
you like them then you don't have to
[__] and listen I have this hippy thing
today all right that's it that's the
Monday morning podcast god bless all you
and it's off to Chicago and let's move
in there I'll talk to you guys what the
[__] is it next Monday alright
happy July 4th weekend god bless america
and you know stop taking [__] from
American Airlines and other airlines and
stop taking [__] from these corporations
go to their websites and complain use a
lot of words like outrageous ridiculous
try to go to privately-owned [__] that's
what I like doing I try to do that then
you go in there and they [__] all over
the food all over the spoon I mean this
is food all over the spoon
Scot just [__] this is why you know
most people they read the dyslexic I
like to speak in dyslexia this is why I
became a comedian if you have a [__]
wondered why this is why I did it
because I'm too much of a [__] to exist
in the real world and secondly when I'm
in the real world I like I just keep
hearing this voice over and over I'm
just going this is [__] stupid this
is [__] stupid she's talking stupid
that's all I would hear you know I tried
to sit in the meetings and they talked
about how to make the product better and
to try and increase revenues everyone
was sitting there and they had out
little little notebooks because it was
the 80s early 90s and all [__] right
and [__] down I just said so I couldn't
hear what the person was saying cuz my
brain just kept going this is [__]
stupid this is [__] stupid I don't
wanna do this
I don't want [__] do this alright I
don't [__] do this alright they go
that's my job history before I became a
comedian was me doing one job after
another and hearing a loud voice in my
head going I don't want to [__] do
this so I don't and now I do this and
this is too long all right I'll talk to
you next week have a great week bye
[Music]
Oh
Hey
away
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
I know
[Applause]
[Music]